c'est le retour de plusieurs recettes
qui ont fonctionné pendant le
confinement des dispositifs renforcés et
adapté par rapport à la situation
actuelle d'abord l'activité partielle va
être maintenu au moins jusqu'au 31
décembre 2020 avec une prise en charge
par l'état à hauteur de 84 % du salaire
net des entreprises touchées par le
confinement pour en bénéficier de ce
dispositif
certains secteurs comme l'hôtellerie ou
la restauration conserve une prise en
charge intégrale par l'état ensuite les
fonds de solidarité les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés fermé durant le
confinement peuvent bénéficier d'une
aide mensuelle jusqu'à 10000 euros
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
des secteurs du tourisme de l'hôtellerie
restauration de l'événementiel de la
culture du sport qui reste ouvert
pendant confinement mais qui subissent
une perte du chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 50 % peuvent aussi bénéficier d'une
aide mensuelle jusqu'à 10000 euros
enfin toutes les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés qui rencontre une baisse de
leur chiffre au delà de 50 % peuvent
obtenir une indemnisation pouvant aller
jusqu'à 1500 euros par mois
il ya aussi les exonérations de
cotisations sociales
elle est totale sur les cotisations
sociales pour les entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés fermés administrativement
les pme du tourisme de l'hôtellerie
restauration de l'événementiel de la
culture du sport qui reste ouvert
pendant confinement mais qui perdent 50
% de leur chiffre d'affaires et au delà
seront exonérés des cotisations sociales
patronales et salariales
enfin les prélèvements des travailleurs
indépendants seront suspendus pour ceux
qui connaissent une fermeture
administrative les exonérations seront
total les pge les prêts garantis par
l'état peuvent être demandés jusqu'au 30
juin 2021
le remboursement de ce prêt peut être
étalés jusqu'à 6 ans l'état propose
aussi des prêts directs aux entreprises
sans solution de financement jusqu'à
10000 euros pour les entreprises de
moins de dix salariés jusqu'à 50000
euros pour les entreprises de 10 à 49
salariés
dernière mesure un crédit d'impôt sur
les loyers à hauteur de 30% du montant
des loyers abandonné principales
bénéficiaires les entreprises de moins
de 250 salariés
fermée administrativement ou appartenant
au secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration
et tourisme